SAAD ALI: My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
And today, I have
here with me Janet.
Janet is the co-chair of
the Kubernetes KubeCon
for Seattle this year
as well as for China.
JANET KUO: Yeah, that's right.
SAAD ALI: So Janet, how
did you get involved with,
let's start with Kubernetes.
How did you get involved
with the Kubernetes project
to begin with?
JANET KUO: So I
started with Kubernetes
as my first project at Google.
So in the beginning,
I was interviewing
at a bunch of places.
And then I got a phone call from
Google, and it's Tim Hockin.
He's a principal software
engineer at Google,
and I had a brief
conversation with him.
And he just told me how
great Kubernetes is,
and it's going to
change the world,
and it's still very,
very new at that time.
So I just say, I just think,
I decided to jump in the ship
and go with the Kubernetes team.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
And how long ago was that?
JANET KUO: It's three years ago.
SAAD ALI: Three years.
Congrats.
So since then, you've
been an avid contributor
in the Kubernetes community.
What are some of the things
that you've contributed
to over the last three years?
JANET KUO: So I'm in the
applications special interest
group.
So we mainly focusing on
Kubernetes applications
and your experience running
applications in Kubernetes.
So the workload's API,
and like deployment
API that most people are using,
and the StatefulSet, DaemonSet,
and jobs, current jobs.
Those kind of stuffs.
And recently, I was working
on improving the garbage
collection of resources.
Because I observed that a
lot of users have resources
in their clusters, but they
cannot clean them up very
easily.
So I want to improve
that part as well.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
So it sounds like recently you
switched gears a little bit
and are taking on
the task of leading,
putting together KubeCon, which
this one is 8,000 attendees.
What is that like?
How did you get involved?
And what can you
tell us about that?
JANET KUO: So a lot of people
ask me the same question
about how I get involved.
And how can they sign up.
But actually, I didn't
sign up, and I just
got an email from Dan Kohn.
He's the executive of CNCF.
He just asked me,
hey, Janet, would you
like to be the
co-chair of KubeCon?
I was like, oh,
my god, of course.
Yes!
SAAD ALI: That is awesome.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: Were you
hesitant at all?
Or did you have any
concerns going in?
Or were you just excited?
JANET KUO: I'm just too excited.
And then later, I
figured out, oh, there's
a lot of things going on there.
A lot of those
things that I need
to do that normal attendees
wouldn't know there's
a lot of work there.
SAAD ALI: And so can you
talk about some of that?
What are some of the things
that our audience might not
know about that goes
into putting together
an event like this?
JANET KUO: So first, we
need to review all the CFPs.
So CFP is like a
proposal for your talk.
So we need to review
all of them and pick
the ones that we think
that the community can most
benefit from.
And also, we'll pick some of
the talks as a keynote speeches.
And also, we'll invite
some industry leaders
to give keynotes.
We think they'll bring
some new ideas to us.
And then co-chairs
need to do also do MC.
And we also have a chance
to do our own keynotes.
And that's--
SAAD ALI: You gave your first
keynote this morning, right?
JANET KUO: Oh, I
haven't give it.
SAAD ALI: Oh, I'm sorry.
OK.
That will be tomorrow.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
That will be tomorrow
and on Thursday.
SAAD ALI: That's super exciting.
Are you ready to be in front of
the audience of 8,000 people?
JANET KUO: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: That's super cool.
So what are some of the
things that didn't quite
go as expected that maybe you
would suggest improvements
on in the future?
JANET KUO: For KubeCon?
SAAD ALI: For KubeCon,
event planning, any of that.
JANET KUO: So for example,
I did the co-chair
for both Shanghai and Seattle.
And at that time,
because Shanghai
is the first one in Asia, so
we did a bit of experiment.
For example, we tried
to have people submit
to both conferences at once.
But then later we figured
that caused some confusion
to people.
So we are not going
to do that next year.
So if you want to submit CFP,
you submit to each conference
individually.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
That's super cool.
And so outside of KubeCon,
what are you looking forward
to in the next year in
the Kubernetes community
or anything at large?
JANET KUO: So I think serverless
and Service Mesh is taking off,
and a lot of people are building
applications of Kubernetes.
They are writing
their own operators
to operate their
own applications.
And also, people are building
developer tools for you
to easily create your
operators and things like that.
So I'm very excited
about how people
build on top of Kubernetes.
SAAD ALI: And make it easier
to deploy applications.
JANET KUO: Yeah, exactly.
SAAD ALI: Well,
that sounds awesome.
Thank you very much
for your time, Janet.
And have a great rest
of your KubeCon here.
This is a great event.
Thank you.
JANET KUO: Thank you.
SAAD ALI: All right.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]